are the blades any good no
our blades are great michael dubin is
unquestionably a great entrepreneur
he built dollar shave club from nothing
into a dominant player in the razer
market
and sold the company to unilever for
over a billion
dollars but everyone seems to think he
just got
lucky and he tends to perpetuate this
idea himself
luck absolutely factors into it and any
entrepreneur that tells you that they
didn't get
a little lucky is not being truthful
probably with you
but i've watched michael dubin's career
closely over the past decade and i don't
think luck had
anything to do with his success he
planned and executed every step of
dollar shave club's growth methodically
and always played to his strengths
sure he took a non-traditional path to
entrepreneurship spending years doing
stand-up comedy
and working at advertising agencies but
plenty of successful entrepreneurs come
from unique backgrounds
and there are even other successful
people in technology who studied improv
like dick custolo the former ceo of
twitter entrepreneurship is all about
playing to your strengths
and nearly every skill can be repurposed
to have an impact on your business
if used properly dubin himself admits
that his improv background helped him as
an entrepreneur i think there's a
lot about studying improv that can help
you
in business just the ability to tease
out of thin air the most important ideas
and the most resonant ideas in any
setting is something that you hone
in improv and you don't have a lot of
time to do it leveraging whatever is
unique about your background is clearly
important
but that's still very general advice we
need to dig deeper to understand exactly
what dubin did to make dollar shave club
so successful
fortunately the whole story from idea to
billion dollar sale
can be boiled down to just three key
strategies whenever people discuss
dollar shave club a lot of attention
gets paid to the viral launch video that
duben produced in 2012.
the video got millions of views as soon
as it went live and drove over 12
000 orders which crashed their website
these are amazing results for any
product launch
and naturally the dollar shave club
launch video led many entrepreneurs to
believe that they needed a flashy launch
video
in order to announce their business to
the world but unless you really dissect
what's going on in the video
and how dubin crafted the story around
dollar shave club
you'll just be wasting your time it's
notoriously hard to make an
advertisement go viral big brands spend
millions of dollars producing
ads that they hope will break through
the noise but every year
most ads fall flat and only a few are
remembered but duben knew that his ad
would get views
because of his first key strategy he's a
master of storytelling the idea behind
dollar shave club is extremely simple
it's really just low-cost razor blades
shipped to your door regularly
so you don't forget to buy new ones
that's it but even if you have a really
basic business model
you still need to tell a compelling
story in order to get your customers
attention let's break down dollar shave
club's launch video to illustrate what i
mean here
right off the bat dubin clearly
understands how short attention spans
are on the internet
he introduces himself asks a question
and then
answers that question in just 10 seconds
hi
i'm mike founder of dollarshaveclub.com
what is dollarshaveclub.com
well for a dollar a month we send high
quality razors
right to your door this opening shot is
great because it's very dynamic
he's wearing a collared shirt but his
tie is loose signaling that he's not
like
other stodgy corporate brands there's
also a ton of random toys in the
background
to add texture to the shot and make you
think maybe this guy is a crazy inventor
or something you instantly want to know
more
and he rewards that curiosity
immediately by restating that the blades
are just a dollar
and then asking another question are the
blades any good
no our blades are great dubin really
leans into his comedy background here
and makes sure that he's injecting humor
every few seconds
even if one joke doesn't quite land the
viewer wants to hear the next one
so they stick around the entire ad is a
masterclass in great editing
both the camera and the subject are
always moving which keeps the viewer
engaged and every scene has an
interesting transition from one area to
the next
you get a clear picture of the warehouse
dubin is walking through even though
he's constantly moving around
one minute he's breaking through paper
to deliver the next line the next minute
he's riding on a forklift then he's up
on a table
jumping down while delivering the next
point the movement is dynamic without
being too frenetic so it's extremely
hard to click away while you're watching
and each segment has a little easter egg
in the shot that breaks up the parts
where dubin is just talking to the
camera when he talks about how gentle
the blades are
he shows a toddler holding one of the
razors when he talks about how simple
blades worked fine for previous
generations
he shows an old-timey framed photo and
when he talks about how dollar shave
club ships blades directly to you
he throws the package to someone in a
bear costume which is never explained at
all
except that maybe hairy bears need
shaving when people talk about the
success of this video
they often focus on how incredible it
was that it was filmed in just
one day or that it only cost five
thousand dollars to make but those facts
can be a bit misleading
dubin actually spent over a month
working on the script for this video
and he collaborated with friends of his
who had experience writing great comedy
sketches
to make sure it would land properly
storytelling is incredibly important
when you're launching a consumer brand
especially online because your product
won't be on store shelves immediately
customers won't be able to pick up and
inspect your product in the real world
before they decide to buy you need to
walk them through the narrative of your
business
and make sure that the message sticks in
their mind dubin used humor to grab
everyone's attention
all while delivering key points about
why dollar shave club was solving a real
problem
humor isn't the only way to tell a
powerful story though when we launched
soylent
we told our story in the form of
long-form blog posts that put a heavy
emphasis on data we wanted to create a
new health food
so providing potential customers with
detailed information about our product
and the results we were personally
experiencing really helped win people
over but even though a strong
launch can set you up for success that
alone won't get you to a billion dollar
acquisition
after the hype around your launch dies
down you need to keep growing
and that's where dubin's second key
strategy comes in
he hacked the facebook algorithm nearly
all direct consumer e-commerce companies
spend money on facebook
but few actually make money from these
ads reliably
this is because facebook ads are run on
an auction model
and as soon as your rivals start
competing for ad placements the cost of
each ad
skyrockets lots of companies raise
venture capital only to squander
millions of dollars on facebook ads
that don't really move the needle they
might bring in new customers
but those customers don't spend enough
money to offset the cost of the ads
if you've ever thought about running
online ads you've probably considered
two main platforms facebook and google
both companies have similar offerings
you can run a video or image of your
product along with a simple text
description
and then track how many people see your
ad and click through to your website
even though facebook and google can both
be great sources of growth
if used effectively the two platforms
are more different than you might think
fishing is a useful analogy here as an
entrepreneur it's your job to bring in
as many customers as possible
these customers are like fish peacefully
swimming along
completely unaware that your company
even exists you need to catch these fish
and you have two resources at your
disposal the first is a fishing net you
can drop this net in the middle of a
stream
and just sit there and wait you'll catch
most of the fish that come through that
stream
but if the stream is empty you're out of
luck google is that fishing net
since most google ads are placed on
keyword searches
customers have to be already searching
for the product you're selling
if you've made something completely new
no one will be searching for it
and google ads won't really work for
your business the alternative is a spear
gun
it's more work since you have to swim
out into the ocean and target
individual fish but you aim for whatever
type of fish you like
and there are always lots of fish in the
ocean facebook is the spear gun
the customer doesn't have to be
searching for a specific solution
in order to be targeted by facebook ads
you can hand pick a demographic that you
think would be interested in what you've
made
and show them your ad regardless of what
they're searching for at the time
doomman understood this and leveraged
facebook perfectly before dollar shave
club launched
no one was searching for razer
subscriptions because no one knew they
wanted that
they might have been searching for best
razors but that would have been highly
competitive
instead dubin focused on targeting men
on facebook and educating them on the
benefits of a razor subscription
but the story doesn't end there
advertisers like dollar shave club are
successful on facebook
because they use a strategy called
sequential targeting instead of hitting
a potential customer with an ad
asking them to purchase right away they
start by educating the customer with a
longer highly produced ad
you might have seen some of these
yourself since they tend to stick out in
the feed
there's one particular ad agency by the
name of harmon brothers who's
responsible for over a billion ad views
across the ads that they've produced
these ads can cost hundreds of thousands
of dollars to make
but that's all okay because they're
designed to completely dominate the
facebook algorithm and go viral
because viral ads like these are so
watchable facebook pushes them into
everyone's feeds at ridiculously low
cost
they are genuinely entertaining and
people like watching them
but they don't actually convert on sales
all that well
the secret to these ads is that they are
just meant to get maximum brand exposure
and set up future targeting facebook
knows whether you watch
two seconds of a video or a full minute
and they can use that data to decide
which ads to show you next
people who watch the full video get
flooded with follow-on ads
encouraging them to purchase much more
directly and these ads are the ones that
actually
make money dubin's understanding of this
content strategy
was at the heart of his early marketing
push and a big reason why dollar shave
club
was able to scale so quickly even after
their first viral ad had stopped getting
organic views
success on facebook requires building a
highly specific
audience for your product and the
fastest way to do that
is to broadcast your brand to millions
of people and then
see who paid attention instead of just
swimming in the open ocean with your
spear gun
you're effectively chumming the water
with bait to attract the biggest fish
so if you're thinking about using google
or facebook to promote your new product
it's important to really think about
which platform is right for you
are people searching for this product
already or do you need to educate them
about it first
the answer can tell you a lot about
where you should spend your marketing
dollars
dubin is clearly an expert at marketing
and that makes sense
because he'd worked in marketing for
years before starting dollar shave club
but he also really understands what
makes a great
product product design is as much about
what you don't put in the product
as what you do dubin saw that all the
big razor companies had been racing to
add more and more features to their
products for years
and this wasn't really improving the
customer experience many entrepreneurs
would assume that the solution would be
to add even more features like internet
connectivity
and an app to track your shaving habits
but dubin realized that simplicity
was really all that mattered sure it
helped that he only had access to basic
razer inventory
so his hands were somewhat tied but he
turned his basic product into something
great
with amazing storytelling and a simple
promise of value to the customer
as an entrepreneur it can be easy to get
caught up in trends and want to use all
the latest technology to build your
product but dubin focused on using
technology
only where it would actually help the
customer like the subscription ecommerce
platform that he built
getting razors delivered on a schedule
solved a problem for customers that the
big razer companies had never considered
and that set dollar shave club apart
ultimately customers didn't need
fancier razors they just needed to
replace their existing razors more
frequently and dollar shave club made
that dead simple to do
so remember play to your strengths tell
a great story
and focus on what's actually important
to your customer and your startup will
grow
if you want to chat about startups you
can always dm me on twitter
and please check out this recommended
video the youtube algorithm thinks that
you'll really like it